that's why they keep bombing the people
and spoiling the life like the hospitals
even the bakeries the anything that
gives them life because they want the
people to leave their places likewise
they did in 1948 they came in in gangs
basically and they started shooting
randomly people in order to take over
the lands and maybe some of you may hear
this for the first time my grandfather
actually was shot there in Gazza my
grand your grandfather my grandfather
1948 so he was part of what be called
the nakba nakba the first neba my
mother's family used to live in Gaza
because Gazza was ruled by Egypt so she
used to live there and they they came
randomly shooting people they shot my
grandfather and my grandmother has to
bury and flee to to Egypt with my mother
and two brothers